[Applauso]
buongiorno a tutti
ho sempre pensato ai miei sogni come
qualcosa da raggiungere come qualcosa di
raggiungibile
ho sempre pensato alla distanza fra me e
loro come lo spazio che mi separava da
loro e fin da piccoli ci hanno sempre
insegnato che lo spazio almeno dal punto
di vista matematico fisico non è altro
che velocità per tempo e dunque mi sono
sempre detto se la distanza fra i miei
sogni è una questione di spazio allora
sarà soltanto una questione di quanta
velocità riuscirò a sostenere per piano
piano raggiungere il mio sogno in
un'unità di tempo insomma qualcosa di
misurabile qualcosa che è
scientificamente
matematicamente possiamo prevedere
calcolare e possiamo orientarci
sapete fin da piccolo come tanti altri
miei coetanei come tanti altri piccoli
sognatori il mio più grande sogno quello
che faceva ogni volta ogni sera quando
andavo a dormire era un giorno calcare
l'erba di san siro con la maglia del mio
amato milan e magari chissà a segnare in
un derby far vincere lo scudetto alla
mia squadra
anche qui era solo una questione di
spazio era solo una questione di quanto
tempo ci avrei impiegato in base alla
velocità che sarei riuscito a sostenere
una questione misurabile
scientificamente misurabile e che non
avrebbe avuto variabili ma spesso questo
l'ho imparato nella mia breve vita e
devo dire che la matematica la scienza
non è non sono sempre applicabili a
pieno a quella che la nostra esistenza
infatti nel febbraio 2005 ho conosciuto
la mod anzi ho avuto la fortuna di
conoscerla mav
per semplificare una fissa la artero
venosa che ha colpito il mio midollo ho
avuto la fortuna di conoscerla ma vi
dico la fortuna e grazie a lei perché
attraverso l'amavo ho conosciuto il
nuoto ho conosciuto quell'elemento che
ha reso particolare speciale forse anzi
normale la mia vita ma soprattutto è
quell'elemento
ha cambiato è quell'elemento che ha
determinato una brusca virata forse la
virata più importante della mia vita ne
faccio tante centinaia al giorno ma
quella è stata quella che mi ha permesso
di cambiare l'orizzonte con cui ho
guardato agli spazi che da qui in avanti
avrei vissuto
eh sì perché con l'amavo conosciuto il
mondo della fisioterapia ho conosciuto
il mondo della medicina e soprattutto
cambiato quel sogno ho cambiato quel
sogno che mi vedeva un giorno calcare
l'erba di san siro in chissà sul giorno
tornerò a camminare
ed ecco perché ed ecco l'elemento del
tempo anche qui l'elemento tempo che è
questione principale nel mio sport nel
nuoto lo è stato per tutta la mia vita
come lo spazio del resto perché appunto
lo spazio non è altro che questione di
tempo
ed ecco che noi non potevamo
non sprechi non non sfruttare ogni
frammento del nostro tempo e così di
giorno andavamo a fare fisioterapia di
giorno cercavamo che io mi convincesse
ad entrare l'acqua e di notte invece
anche lì i sogni continuano ad andare
avanti e il tempo continua a scorrere e
quindi neanche lì potevamo perdere del
tempo e anche lì lo sfruttavamo
utilizzavamo dei tutori che tenevano i
miei piedi fermi permettevano loro di
avere una posizione più consona visto
che non riuscivo a controllarli
ma soprattutto devo dire grazie alla mav
perché grazie a quel febbraio 2005 ho
capito che i nostri sogni si sono
irraggiungibili o meglio non possono
essere calcolati non possono essere
preparati non possono essere programmati
in fondo della nostra vita se pensiamo
bene
sì noi la crediamo nostra e lo diciamo è
nostra è la nostra vita ma in realtà non
è così
la nostra vita è un po come un quadro
non sappiamo mai se avremo bisogno di
dieci cento mille diecimila centomila un
milione di pezzi per completarla non
sapremo mai se avremo bisogno di pezzi
gialli rossi verdi
neri blu insomma non sappiamo niente
stabilità perché non sappiamo neanche in
che misura e come collocare questi pezzi
come collocare il giallo come quello che
era il rosso insomma non sappiamo niente
della nostra vita
eppure ogni giorno ci sforziamo di
programmarla di determinarla di fissare
degli obiettivi di fissare dei piccoli
punti che piano piano la completeranno
insomma grazie alla mav
oggi sono qui
sono nella mia stanza sul letto della
mia stanza il telefono continua di
illuminarsi e io sono contento sì perché
molte persone furono lasciandomi dormire
e domani avrò i 400 stile libero
continuano a trasmettermi il loro
affetto la loro vicinanza e lo spazio
che c'è fra me e quella stanza di tokyo
e loro in italia sembra quasi annullarsi
insomma
ripenso sono contento certo oggi forse è
stato il giorno più importante della mia
vita
ho vinto due edizioni di europei ho
vinto due edizioni del mondiale
e oggi ho vinto la paralimpiade con il
record del mondo nei 100 stile libero
che la gara regina del nostro sport la
gara regina del moto
insomma sono contento si per il
risultato sportivo sono contento perché
le scelte che ho fatto in questi anni
che mi hanno accompagnato lungo la
carriera sportiva si sono realizzate è
tutto come lo aspettavo ma sono
soprattutto contento perché ripeto ho
capito che la nostra vita è troppo
imprevedibile per far sì che ogni giorno
noi possiamo alzarsi e dire voglio
raggiungere quel sogno perché quel sogno
è quello spazio che c'è fra noi e il
nostro sogno è incolmabile in
programmabile almeno scientificamente eh
sì perché non sappiamo né cosa ci
riserverà allo spazio della nostra vita
né quanto ne avremo ancora a
disposizione insomma è sempre ed è
ancora la questione di tempo tutto lo
spazio che abbiamo davanti è che noi non
possiamo controllare va ottimizzato va
sfruttato
ed ecco è vero la nostra vita è
imprevedibile
probabilmente i nostri sogni sono
irrealizzabili
però una cosa che ho capito che cerco di
applicare ogni giorno è che noi non
possiamo smettere di sognare non
possiamo smettere di credere in un
obiettivo non possiamo smettere
desiderare qualcosa
più semplicemente non possiamo smettere
di desiderare di vivere
insomma anche se la nostra vita avrà
bisogno di un milione di pezzi iniziamo
dai primi dieci e soprattutto anche se
la nostra vita anche se il quadro della
nostra vita
al termine avrà uno spazio un buco che
noi reputiamo brutto antiestetico in
realtà quello il momento più bello della
nostra vita e lo spazio più bello di
quel quadro e lo spazio che la nostra
vita dedicato a noi e noi abbiamo
dedicato alla nostra vita per imparare
per trasmettere qualcosa a noi e agli
altri per vivere qualcosa a pieno
insomma proprio quello spazio che
pensiamo sia mancante in realtà è lo
spazio più pieno della nostra vita
quindi
aggiungo la conclusione è importante sì
partire dal presupposto che
probabilmente non realizzeremo neppure
un nostro sogno ma importante secondo me
alzarsi la mattina con il sorriso aprire
la finestra e appunto sorridere la vita
desiderare di vivere desiderare un
giorno di tuffarsi in piscina a
desiderare un giorno di scoprire un
nuovo spazio desiderare insomma di
scoprire qualcosa che non possiamo
scoprire appieno qualcosa che non
possiamo programmare appieno
l'importante però è appunto alzarci
svegliarci soprattutto e sorridere la
vita perché aprendo quella finestra
avremo un mondo di fronte si sconosciuto
si imprevedibile ma un mondo fantastico
per questo grazie
[Applauso]